do you anticipate that the realized
price could make a massive downturn like
pretty much it's you know usually kind
of flat to up just given the way that
it's calculated uh as kind of like a a
a type of moving average if you will um
is there a world where
we could see it materially go down like
could we see realize price go down
twenty percent uh of the actual space
not where the price of bitcoin is
trading below the real estate but like
realize price actually go down like that
or is that less likely just given the
dynamics of the market and kind of how
that's calculated
it's definitely it's definitely possible
and you know currently around 10 below
uh below it's all-time high it goes down
or trends up based on whether whether
coins are being spent right if they're
like spent i mean being moved from the
from the last time they were they're
moved on chain uh at a profit or a loss
and so obviously there's a little bit of
noise in the metric right if i transfer
coins to cold storage and then i just
reshuffle them to a different you know
cold storage or a multi-sig wallet and
i'm not actually spending them but it's
moving the realized price says hey like
that's an economic spend at a profit or
a loss but
kind of in aggregate on average it's a
pretty useful tool right so like
obviously not every spend is economic
but uh realized price could you know in
theory go down 20 25 like it has in
previous times uh if we see a lot of
still kind of uh higher buys right
people that bought it sixty thousand
fifty thousand forty thousand a lot of
these these coins have already
capitulated that's why we've seen uh the
realized price go from say 25k which it
was hovering around for a while to now
like 22 but it could still go lower if
more if more kind of previous top buyers
capitulate right so i think for the most
part anybody that's here and hasn't kind
of capitulated or hasn't been a
foreseller
is kind of just in it for the long haul
that's usually why we see bitcoin bottom
it's kind of a sunk cost fallacy to say
hey like
my average buy is is underwater i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna hold on to this
thing and ride it out um funny enough
not funny enough but uh for the first
time ever actually bitcoins below its
200-week moving average so what does
that mean uh the average four-year dc
air for like the first time in bitcoin's
history is underwater so like just in
terms of in terms of sentiment in terms
of just like historic levels of of down
only uh we're there we see it uh
certainly it doesn't mean that more
downside can't happen um and everybody
needs to be prepared for it uh mentally
but uh you know in terms of long-term
asymmetry never mind the short to the
immediate term uh you know this is going
to be looked back on as one of the best
times to buy bitcoin i think over the
next three to six months
yeah and so when you start to look at uh
maybe the on-chain metrics things around
the bitcoin market there's been a number
of commentators uh and analysts who have
said look we can do all this analysis
but the macro environment is this like
hangover uh on it how do you think about
balancing those two right so the onsha
investors are saying hey look we're
trading below realized price there's
been this significant drawdown
historically some of the drawdowns have
been more some of them have been around
this level uh and i think most people if
they just were evaluating that data set
would be pretty excited right now if
your goal was to acquire uh more bitcoin
but the macro seems to be like this huge
question mark and so like how do you
think about balancing those two
yeah so i've always kind of thought of
the the on chain as like this this long
term
maybe not even not even quarter to
quarter like year over year cycle by
cycle to cycle uh type framework right
you can kind of get a general sense of
when things are overvalued or
undervalued um but yeah the macro is
definitely the driver i i'm of the
opinion that we're we're headed for kind
of some some point of singularity where
uh you're seeing all this craziness all
this upheaval all of this unrest uh you
know politically and socially around the
world uh and economically right
the eurozone is a total mess the
japanese yen is melting down the dollar
store soaring higher credit markets are
melting down um i think in terms of the
equity markets the first leg of the
drawdown was all about duration right so
yields went from basically zero to you
know two three uh three and a half
percent and so what did that do it
crushed that kind of the multiple side
of the stock uh now equity markets the
next big concern is the consumer's been
getting killed because of inflation
right so now the earnings are are that
kind of uh
are the the next leg down i think it was
first it was about duration now it's
about earnings um so i i still believe
and and why i still have some cash on
the side is i believe that we have uh
we're going to reach kind of this this
correlation to one moment right
obviously bitcoins correlated to the to
the nasdaq to the s p 500 to equity
indices uh and when you know those are
down bitcoins down more and recently
when those are up bitcoin's been kind of
just sitting flat which is a little
worrisome but i still think we're gonna
see this this huge whether it's a limit
down day in equities uh or some you know
credit market breaking or some something
breaking in the currency markets uh
we're going to see something in the
financial system break and that's going
to be the cause for a fed pivot i think
a a soft landing is somewhat laughable
and so that's why i still have some kind
of buying power on the sidelines because
it's completely exogenous to bitcoin
itself and you know the bitcoin network
is 100 uptime nothing has changed about
the underlying thesis
but it's not insulated against these
these broader markets right bitcoin is
still just a drop in the bucket in terms
of the global financial assets uh and
when the bond market's gurgling and
something breaks then you know the
liquidity the liquidity effects of that
are obviously going to make its way into
the bitcoin market so dawn chain is a
useful framework for for you know six
months a year
four years right it's this kind of cycle
by cycle like is it undervalued is a
little bit overvalued should i wait uh
but the macro right now is obviously the
driver and i think really every asset on
the planet is is a kind of a function of
the liquidity tide being pulled out or
or being pushed you know kind of pushed
onto land